[Music]
all right welcome to the new episode of
the exit strategy podcast we're here
with Chris Davis from week great Chris
super excited to meet you you and I have
never chatted before which rarely
happens to newcomers industry super
excited to get to chat today yeah now
excited to be here and looking forward
to it and super good to connect so loot
crate is a subscription box to geeky
products for $20 a month or around that
price point is that a fair way to
describe loot crate or is that
completely that's I mean that's kind of
the origins of loot crate and one of our
products now but you know we've gotten
into you know it's 25 different
subscription lines bunch of different
price points and offerings but the
original concept was $20 comic-con in a
box all the best products across pop
culture getting 40 to 60 dollars a value
for that 20 and and in this really
curated experience so that's the origin
but it's evolved quite a bit yeah is
this one of those instances where like
the origin is still the bread and butter
of the business like a native deodorant
is the bread and butter of the business
or is this the place where the origin is
like you know ancient history like
Amazon like okay yeah we sell books boom
sell everything else do you know it's so
far bigger all largest product line and
really have that holistic I anything
across gaming film entertainment yeah
genre deal yep gotcha and when did the
business launch what did you guys like
actually start the business we launched
it in 2012 and actually launched a
dentist at a startup weekend in Los
Angeles and had gone to a bunch for fun
and it was like this there's no better
place to launch a new company then
Startup Weekend what happened to sort of
like do you go on on stage to like pitch
the business or like what does it
Startup Weekend it's literally a two-day
hackathon I met my co-founder there so
we you know had everything teed up
launched it and business took off kind
of from day one there and we were
shipping a product 30 days later
did you come up with a concept during
the hackathon or no that came in with
the concept which one - okay but are you
watching 2012 I've done a bunch of
research about Luke ray
I'm a huge fan of the business by 2016
you're doing a hundred million dollars
in revenue now we're doing 100 we're
doing like a hundred and seventy million
revenue 2016 yeah a hundred seventy no
you're number one on the fastest o on
the list of fastest growing e-commerce
companies by Inc I read that in 2014 two
hundred thousand subscribers
2016 you've tripled that you have six
hundred thousand subscribers not a
percent so tell me how the hell you
built a business to do a hundred
you know twenty twenty twelve ecommerce
is not what it is today I was in
ecommerce in 2012 you were at you're
trying to buy Facebook Likes which meant
nothing when you post it on your page on
Facebook there were still a bunch of
people who are like actively engaged on
that today if you do that zero people
respond like how do you build a business
with like you know I we interviewed the
Hubbell contacts guys and Jesse was like
ask Jesse how would you spend your first
you know that with $10,000 is like
Facebook Instagram Instagram what did
you do in 2012 so yeah we you know
primarily didn't do any of the kind of
traditional paid Facebook until 2014
really on the on ad side we were our
largest channel was Influenster and
really like all the new YouTube
celebrity folks coming up my brother had
been early to maker studio and launched
the channel doing video and sketch
comedy
my co-founder Matt had worked and
managed much those guys so we
immediately you know you mean that first
weekend we're already pulling in some of
these large creators with big followings
and so we're closely there and then
scaled up we were originally with any
paid spend on Facebook for the first two
years was on building that our pages
like yeah and do it all that yeah and
then Facebook was like none of that no
more that so yeah we were you know that
was yeah Facebook and some of those
channels were really pretty small for us
until a couple years oh yeah Facebook
didn't have like an ad so in 2012 you're
buying YouTube influence or you're
getting YouTube influencers to speak
about the product yeah exactly you know
traditional kind of performance
affiliate deals in agreeing some of them
we integrate actually in is gave a qui
to some of the larger ones that we want
to be a part of business
for a long time but yeah it was you know
the product was super compelling and
shareable for that yeah and so
integrating the business from day one
and so we were yeah we were distributing
product they were you know opening each
month and sharing it with all of our
subscribers yeah and so like you know
today I I look when I was running native
at a really difficult time getting
influencers to do any pay for
performance or like affiliate they were
all like no no no no you need to give us
X amount of cash before we do this thing
and we don't care how many sales we get
look some people would wasn't true for a
hundred percent of the cases but it's
true for ninety percent of the cases
back in 2013 2012 2014 are people still
doing paper performance uh totally and I
think obviously there was that time -
all the ncns were scaling up so there
was like you know as a mix of like there
were now these professional ad sales
teams coming out a big media companies
manage these guys yeah it's charged
massive amounts of money that weren't
economic yeah but a lot of I think they
also charge more for products that
weren't on brand so when you're doing
like a big CPG integration you're gonna
and brand on the other side if you're
brand they like to work with
we were network directly that way are
you still doing a lot of like paper
pay-for-performance type of deal build
score is it now generally sort of
shifted to we're a brand as well we have
to pay you up front we've done both I
mean we've spent and I think it comes
down to it was everything from you know
PewDiePie who's number one yeah and so I
think we've had flexible approaches a
lot of it comes back to just that cack
math of we were doing it's up we had
five or six hundred active influencers
so we had really great data on view
through click-through conversion rates
so you could almost yeah people wanted
flat fee payments you could calculate
what the equivalent would abandon so
yeah just a discipline approach there
but yeah we weren't it changed quite a
bit into 2015 2016 and I think the
markets even shifting again now with a
lot of the ncns dial yak and now the CPM
is on YouTube coming down in the last
couple months and so I guess to quote
one is do you how many people does it
take on your team to manage five or six
hundred look you know influencers that
we had one Kurt yeah yeah how big is
that team that team at that time when it
was it kind of it
pekes been for us which was in 2016-2017
was five folks folks managing 500 people
yeah cuz yeah well some of its high
touch some of its low touch and so you
know we use basic CRM to communicate and
there's a lot of automation game product
out and we try to make the deals simple
enough in her people enough it wasn't
yeah taking that touch to attend the day
these are folks that we want to make
sure we had had people available to talk
to yeah and what were the types of look
did you guys test offers with the
influencers and if so what would the
offers that worked yeah I mean it was
really the pretty basic they should be
able to have a discount code for their
audience for rewarding him there and
really unboxing and showing the product
was always the winning approach you know
doing a little pre-roll or mid-roll ads
it does it it's not nearly as effective
same thing with podcasts which is I
think a very similar marketing medium
like having somebody open talk about the
products be genuinely excited always
worked the best for us yeah it's crazy
how much authenticity still gets through
with like um you know paid influencers
its look somehow you still can't fake it
no I mean as a marketer you're like you
don't want it to you know as a consumer
you know is the marketer sometimes
you're optimistic this you know less
authentic more scalable approach is
gonna work but it never does yeah but
you know what I'm watching Game of
Thrones I'm like okay all of these guys
are Duke like oh my god there's this
epic battle it's gonna like Westeros
forever and whoever dies is gonna die
but they're there's no off like I know
what's going on there's no authenticity
and yet I mean like you know it's so
engaged and what an influencer is like
popular product versus genuinely excited
about it it's so clear I don't know I'm
not sure if they're not as good actors
or if it's just like you know human
beings have sort of been like have their
own my detector and why big things we
can figure it out and that's I think the
influences they are the ultimate
entrepreneurs these guys had no startup
capital and build an audience of
millions so their currencies always been
being authentic and yeah that fanbase so
we found over time was they were never
willing to sacrifice that authentic
genuine relationship with their viewers
on behalf of some brand who's gonna come
and go oh I think it makes the unit
really well when they do because you
know their their main currency is being
you know trusted by their fan base yeah
and so are you still working with any of
the influencers that you started working
with in 2012 like has anyone lasted
eight years yes I'm have some I mean a
lot of those folks have shifted their
approach and and of course this will
move now you know some people are twitch
exclusive some people are it's been
really to watch the evolutionary but
yeah we're still working with folks from
from back that era and so like 2014 year
of 200,000 subscribers 2016 600,000
subscribers at what point do you fund
rates we so we had taken a really small
seed check 25k right when we launched
and then we didn't raise again until we
heard one hundred and fifty million
dollar run rate so we bootstrapped
through you know that whole period until
2016 sorry I my internet cut off a
little bit you took a small seed check
did you say was $25,000 yeah we did a
25k sea check right when we launched
with a couple guys out of LA Nick Groff
Dave Waxman and then and didn't raise
again until that series a until the
series a in 2016 yeah so yeah so you're
profitable you're profitable at 200,000
subscriber
look cuz you're burning there's no way
you just print $25,000 over four years
you must be problem we were operating
essentially it just yeah just below and
at breakeven so we're reinvesting
everything yeah and how many people are
the team before you raise that series a
we're it probably 60 70 folks at that
point okay I know you look tell me
what's going on in your head like you
know when we like when native was doing
well like I was like this can't be
possible like I can't believe
that we didn't have to raise more money
in order to build such a big business
and I also felt like everything was held
together with duct tape because I was
like I don't know when like you know
water stuck in water we're gonna start
leaking on this ship and I really don't
know when like torpedo is gonna hit the
ship and just blow this whole thing
apart never happened I'm like I was
consoling
we worried about that what is going on
in your head when you know you're doing
a hundred million dollars in revenue
you've raised $25,000 and like at the
time like you know you were not you are
not Casper mattresses in bed but not not
as like Casper everybody knew about it
was like this dtc doll a loot crate
wasn't why wasn't it and what's going on
through your head I mean so we were I
mean I think we're doing the right thing
we were marketing to our audience which
is a different segment so we were very
focused on our consumer and so that we
were there I think for us is you know
it's a physical distribution business
they're crazy chaos every day so we were
used to at like that that intensity
level being a hundred percent
direct-to-consumer though we did control
the whole funnel so as long as we had
scaled up different leadership in
another area so everything was working
we controlled fulfillment at point we
were working primarily with third-party
manufacturers on products and so you
know the complexity scaled up yeah month
to month and so you just got used to you
know more more of that craziness but no
a lot of it was just like you said heads
down if there's a problem solve it and
then yeah really just scaling up you
know capabilities across all those areas
is there like um is there that you know
for me I felt both terrified and
invincible which is really weird
dichotomy right by God to be you feel
like nothing can ruin this but you also
feel like everything is gonna
ruin this you do have that feeling or
were you just like I'm in the weeds I
don't really have time to appreciate
what's going on on a like you know on a
month on a corner over the corner so
well I mean that feel like you said that
feeling is there depending on when
things are going really well when
they're not well you're in that rapid
growth mode there's a lot of things
going really well but behind that
there's all the things that you're
trying to keep moving forward so we had
you know port strikes and product
recalls and like all kinds of crazy
problems that come up to feel very
existential in the moment that you just
you know try to try to have some like
perspective on after the fact but yeah
you're you know cortisol levels spike
yeah where you're just like there's a
port strike and like you know for for a
long time like when you're growing up
and you see something on the news or
you're like there's a port strike you
just like whatever just okay now
all of a sudden you're like you dump
get back to work I need to ship
this product like can we cuckoo can we
call it the port just get our prize it's
like you really go does back-row Venza
got okay Chris we're talking about port
strikes and existential threats you're
feeling invincible and beautiful at the
same and then we were talking about like
the boxes and like what you sort of had
in the boxes you had exclusive you'd
like Star Wars boxes halo boxes you were
doing your licensing IP is that correct
so initially we were working primarily
with third-party manufacturers and then
we scaled up our own internal product
capabilities later so we were basically
going out and saying what's the coolest
product yeah that no one knows about
finding it and then working with you
know 200 plus suppliers to create
something each month each box had four
or five items and really we said we
could you know buy anything across the
entire licensed product landscape so we
were buying books apparel collectibles
you know early I even shipped some DVDs
when I was still thinking so I was like
anything that needed to be out there we
would go and find and then partner with
companies to produce and then you
ultimately got to exclusive products is
that right like at some point you were
like making products other people have
that you had exclusive products very
early even we were working with third
parties to produce exclusive products
for us
and which is a big part of the in the
license product space they'll do an
exclusive variant that shows up if it's
you know think about a collectible
something like that so we would produce
we work with other companies would
produce exclusive product with them so
did you have to go to a Lucasfilm to try
and get that exclusivity or those
licensing fees or did you just go to
this third party manufacturer and that
sort of had those already so that was
that was kind of Phase two for us where
we actually started taking direct
licenses ourselves at the beginning we'd
go and find somebody that already had
that license and work with them on a
product and then over time we got to a
big enough scale where we started to
take more that in in-house directly
gotcha
okay all right so let's look rewind or
fast-forward again to 2016 you raise a
Series A it's 18 million dollars it's
led by upfront is that right yeah and
who's the partner on the
is it more stuff than somebody else Greg
that Nelly okay and then you've got like
III read that you also have like Robert
Downey jr. in the round as well or like
it is Ventura yeah exactly this venture
arm came in and often co-invest with
upfront those guys that's great and so
ultimately how many people like putting
the money to get to 18 million dollars
up front was a large jack I think there
was five or six other investors
alongside up okay gotcha and then I read
somewhere that you're still a fifty look
you were the 51% shareholder or
something to that effect
after this round of capital between you
your co-founder and all these guys you
still a large chunk of the shares is
that correct yeah but you my co-founder
myself and then my company equity yeah
because we didn't really we hadn't
raised before so we common still had a
large portion of the company yeah and so
tell me a little bit about how look what
made you raise and yeah tell me what
made you rates like how do you go you
you went from zero dollars to a hundred
sixty million dollars in revenue in four
years which is like you know which is
insane especially those four years when
like targeting is what it is but it's
Eve it's absolutely more insane
the idea that you did it with $25,000
what ultimately makes you raise money so
I think you know we spent a lot we
actually kept very disciplined folks on
that single lootcrate product for the
first three and a half years and really
refine the model we did a ton of user
testing and the actual like product
experience got dramatically better over
time so we got to a point where we
thought it was you know we needed to
start expanding out into essentially
different fan verticals and so you know
also one to start taking in licensing
in-house which comes with a lot of
upfront commitments and guarantees and
just a lot more upfront investment and
then we were working on a bunch of
vertical expansion so we had you know
the major league baseball and NBA teed
up to launch a sports vertical and and
then really we had one engine one stop
for engineer to two hundred thousand
subs and you know we were trying to get
a lot more complexity the model need to
build that yeah warm around custom text
so just investing in data science team
and
Janene team and then a lot more in house
probably development folks um we just
were kind of gonna go to this when you
have 600,000 subscribers you have one
engineer no 7007 that I put we had five
or six engineers and you having to take
on more the development early but up
through 200,000 we were just leveraging
a lot of the existing depress software I
think it's a good lesson for a lot of DC
folks just like you know especially
where shop fights today versus where it
was then you really can get to a pretty
massive scale before you need to invest
a lot in custom development and so you
know we were when we when we raised it
was say hey we think there's you know in
the two hundred and sixty billion dollar
license consumer products basically
there's a lot of there's a lot of room
to scale and grow and if we're gonna do
that we need to raise you know more
capital to to invest in that in that and
then really you know ramped up yeah and
you're not on Shopify back then right
you like Shopify isn't what it is today
you're sort you're building out your own
custom tech exactly yep we were using
we're currently and charge fire Leon and
a bunch of these like basically built
for enterprise software companies that
we were gonna pack it together and then
why 18 like how did you get to eighteen
million dollars you know uh a hundred
seventy million dollar a year business
can get I can raise way more than that
but I can't imagine you would like I
can't imagine that it's hard to find
investors and I can't imagine that was
hard to raise more money than that why
did you choose eighteen million dollars
well I actually was not it was not an
easy time to raise back if you remember
2015 2016 there was you know challenges
of China there was a bunch of large econ
companies that have had some challenges
and raised big rounds so it actually was
not a particularly easy time to raise
and we raised actually on we did 18 and
a half of equity and fifteen of debt at
the same time so the total raised up one
was like thirty 33 million in an
accommodation of debt equity so blamin
so we need we did bring in more capital
but what actually was not the easiest
time for for econ
raises just because I think a lot of you
know fab had had some child there's like
a bunch of yeah there was a there had
been a big in 2013 2014 a ton of
investing to the space and I think some
folks have gotten burned there
that's crazy how like how quickly people
forgot right if it was there people
forgot about fad 2015 20 2015 start to
raise by 2018 you were back in it right
like we're like great let's write huge
checks to every single
direct-to-consumer business over
capitalize that and we'll like you know
we'll hopefully we will pay for this
later or somebody else will pay for
cycles are like seventeen Spanish flu
that we're repeating go bid this is like
oh yeah I forgot what happened 24 months
ago like I've got milk in my fridge that
that's bad old you know my god that's
crazy
all right so you've raised thirty
million dollars or around thirty million
dollars between equity and debt at that
point and then business gets much
tougher yes yeah I think tell me like
yeah tell me what happened like what
happened like ultimately like you know
the wheels start falling off but tell me
how things went from 170 million to the
wheel starting to fall off so I think
the it comes out of that we were raising
to launch and expand both the team
internally and then the product
offerings and a lot of our own
capabilities all the same time I think
big lesson was just like execution risk
at scale becomes much more real and we
had a lot of concurrent bets out that
we're straining business so yeah I think
we when we raised we definitely ramped
up burn ramped up marketing spend ramped
up all that I think we went from you
know just a couple product lines to a
dozen different tension lines very
quickly and so had challenges around
inventory and forecasting so we're
assuming like our core business could
continue to grow exponentially at the
same time as we're marketing other
product lines it didn't that didn't work
as well we then built out like these
brand teams and we're trying to
distribute purchasing and PNL
responsibilities to folks that hadn't
really had to do it at scale before so
we had some margin compression like
there was all these little things that
kind of chip away and then on top of
that you know I think the actual product
offering itself well that was
was doing very well you just we
basically were scaling op X and and team
Sizemore quickly the business had been
growing and so you know burned through
cash to quickly and and so then we you
know kind of had to go into a pivot mode
where we were you know then less of a
growth orientation and more of a you
know efficiency profitability
orientation plus we had a large
outstanding debt facility which creates
a whole others that I can you know of
complexity so so let's start first with
just like a shift from going from no
burnt and starting to burn money from a
mental perspective is that difficult to
do I look at native you know we didn't
burn money and then all the sudden we
had you know I was constantly worried
about running out of you know we'd raise
$500,000 we were sort of operating like
you guys were I was like if there's a
big if something goes wrong or if we
make a big mistake or if I make a big
mistake myself I'm not sure the business
can afford it and like once we had P&G
is backing it was hard for me to
mentally shift it to the phase where I
could be where I was like you know what
we can afford to make a big mistake now
and I think as a result of not being
able to take advantage of that balance
sheet I made a mistake by not taking
advantage of it was it difficult for you
to make that shift for being like cash
flow neutral to burning money mentally
or were you just like hey I know how
this works and I know we raised this
money we're gonna put yeah I think you
know it's there's like the basic
operating metrics so you're like you're
kacct LTV ratio less stuff so you're
tracking a lot of those operating
metrics closely so you can feel good
about the investments you're making you
when the burns there I think just the
complete report and complexity of above
that larger nor we had 300 full-time
employees than another 250 temp
warehouse folks that point so just
there's a lot of scale and a lot of burn
Wow you did your own concealment yeah we
were yeah the hundred thousand square
feet in LA where we're doing fulfillment
and so there was and it's also a bigger
ship to turn so I think there was just a
number of of you know we it just it's
it's difficult to
in multiple modes at once I think we'll
get into more kind of as we talk to
challenge but like growth lean
efficiency cost-cutting
it's hard to be with mine that's the
same time and I think as the leaders you
scale your gets bigger you're in more
markets you're more channels you have
more product lines you're really handing
off responsibilities and so those areas
and you're you're choosing where you're
focusing and so it's yeah there's just a
lot more to manage
yeah and so you're starting your like
creating a bunch of new boxes and you
must be skilled Morgan's plan at the
same time in order to try and grow that
but like you know continue that
exponential growth where are you
spending marketing dollars in 2016 to
2018 you should sort of trying to grow
is it have you shifted from YouTube to
Facebook or is it still primarily yeah
so we I mean we had a big belief in a
lot of these organic channels so one and
really driven by my co-founder or Matt
we had a big social team and we had
social channels for a lot of our
different subscription lines we had a
lot of art you know 30 40 thousand
pieces of organic content crated by our
community and really had a whole engine
around you know working with the
community and reinforcing that we then
had a big investment on the influencer
side still we were spending a large
amount of money by then in on paid
Facebook you know Northey million a
month and then we were doing direct
response television we had a big big
investment podcast we were we've done
probably 70 different conventions which
is a unique part of our industry you
know for the first couple years we
actually a modified school bus that we
would drive around and be our booth in
the these conventions so that was the
in-person piece of it yeah and then tons
of CO marketing so we were working you
know we had Marvel and a crate we would
be working with Marvel social team to
post any of our you know manufacturers
and suppliers that were in the box that
month we'd be Co marketing with so we we
had a whole co-marketing a partnership
set of channels as well that we looked
at but really kind of thinking about you
know what are the proprietary marketing
our streams we can own it or not we're
not gonna be you know put a bid against
everybody on Facebook or Google yeah and
then having those really be kind of
scalable predictable channels alongside
those
and so when you're starting to negotiate
like well let me start with another
question or 20 just 2017 and 2017 do you
grow beyond your 2016 numbers or is
there contraction no that's what we
started to pull back beginning in 2017
at that point yeah I've got to and so 20
looks sort of the peak is 2016 2017 ish
P from Marvel and sort of working on
exclusive products does that do and
you're like sort of working with Marvel
and not manufacture for that licensing
does that licensing make up a
significant part of your cost of goods
sold
it's it varies a bit but yeah it ends up
being you know the average licensing
rates or you know 10 to 15% on cost of
goods so it ends up being GATS material
to margin yeah yeah yeah I think
everyone's always curious when like a
plushie doll comes out I'm always like
how much of this money goes to Luke
George Lucas the Lucasfilm and how much
of it goes to you know Harry Potter of
you versus like natural person
manufactured a horse a little bit yeah
it's a ten to fifteen percent six
percent across yeah every if you're you
know if you're Star Wars you get you
know if they're like 18 percent 20
percent sometimes but yeah that's
alright that range
yeah and it sounds like there is a one
huge mistake that where like there's a
one big thing that you point to you're
like this is the mistake we made that
sort of made us pull back on the
business it's sort of like a bunch of
little Nick's now as you're expanding
your expanding channels you're expending
the technical offer you're distributing
P&L responsibility from yourself to
other managers and all that chips away a
little bit to ultimately like cost you
the growth trajectory that you sort of
want to be on totally I mean I think the
other big thing is once you you know
once you have capital partners in the
business then you know there's a lot of
alignment and you know getting everyone
on the same page to get things done and
especially with debt if you you know if
you're missing your covenants your
default on your loan you know yeah
lenders are it's much more of a scaled
t2c company problem but yeah you know
debt has very different dynamics than
then equity and
so we were dealing with a lot of of
complexity on that side of the business
that you know it was definitely
impacting focus on the other side the
business we really just decide we gotta
we have to we have to cut back costs to
get to a sustainable level and so look
was your cat going up a lot at this time
was this more of an effects problem or
was this of we're spending a lot of
money on marketing problem okay it
wasn't in cat had been fairly stable I
think there's definitely like increasing
costs and some of the like you know the
bigger channels like Facebook things
like that that everyone was seeing
around that time is more dollars moving
there but this was definitely you know
more of a kind of a structural business
issue
gotcha and so ultimately tell me a
little bit about the dynamics with debt
like what was you know I understand it
they're like you know equity is very
different debt equity sort of along
arrived and gets paid when you get paid
a debt you've got not only to pay them
on a monthly basis but also covenants
where they're like you have to hit
certain metrics otherwise you're in
default of our obligations was it like
where's the debt it's tough to deal with
were they constantly calling you and
being like hey you're not also like did
they fit like you said you would raise
fifteen million dollars in debt do they
think that there were fifteen million
dollars in assets if they foreclosed
upon business or if they took possession
of the business that they would get
their money back
you know you didn't it doesn't get to
that level really quickly folks are
trying to work through just like what's
the plan right so without we worked
through it for quite a while and ended
up refinancing them in 2018 and a lot of
it is just you know that trying to align
you know we were looking at bringing in
new new capital at the same time as we
were cutting costs yeah try to achieve
profitability so we're out trying to
raise equity with you know top-line not
growing the way it had been so it what
it does I think you know the more
complexity in the capital structure it
the you know more misalignment there
could be just in like near term and
medium term objectives you know and so
yeah you know there's a learning curve
there and figure out you know how to
manage those those aspects
and it's taking up a lot of your heads
face it's like it sounds like it did
because you sort of you have to like not
only do you have to manage the equity
guys you got to manage the deck guys
you're gonna refinance you wanna fund
raise again
sounds like the dead guys like it just
sounds like it would take up all your
mental energy is that right or is this
sort of like is this so I'm focusing on
this one day a quarter sort of type of
thing or is this uh actually this is
bothering me every like there's a little
thing in the back of my head that I'm
always thinking about it's not going
away
slash I'm thinking about a full-time
once a week no it's yes you know for you
know probably two years it's about 75%
of my time right and I'm really letting
the kind of yeah managing all that
everything surrounding that all of the
complexity generated by you know
figuring out 75% is in a state amount of
time insane no for sure and that's why I
think yeah it is insane about time but
it is that point you know that the you
know the reality and the you know and
the most important thing that I can do
we had a great team of operators in
place too but yeah it was you know I
think the lesson to a lot of folks is is
you know I think everyone's probably
seeing it now with kovat and just
strains on businesses is that like
margin of safety and risk management
which a lot of those of us had like you
know dive headfirst into these
businesses are Pro risk I think you know
the risk management side something I've
become a lot more is if advising folks
and helping people out it's like just
give yourself a lot of margin for error
because if you don't you end up you know
having to spend an enormous amount of
time on things aren't driving customer
value aren't really in like the core
drivers of growth of the business yeah
absolutely look um when native first
raised capital we raised $50,000 within
like the first three or four months of
launching the business and I talked to
my brother about it he actually ran a
mobile gaming company then licensed a
lot of IP so they created like a Harry
Potter game Marvel game Star Wars game
Family Guy game and so I was like you
know we've raised this $50,000 he's like
I would never write you that check and I
was like why wouldn't you write that
track he's like fifty thousand dollars
you get one swing at the bat and if you
don't like Miss that swing
you're out of money and your business is
over and so like nobody wants to put in
$50,000 bank account you're gonna make a
mistake in that 50 thousands gone
quickly if you've got $300,000 you can
like learn from that mistake and swing
again and made me one more time before
you're sort of out of money
totally Mike well I think if you like
and you probably dealt with this quite a
bit but I see it all the time as you
know especially we have inventory too
and you're launching something new a lot
of people get overly optimistic about
like the first run and you're like why
did you just put 40 of your 50k into
inventory you haven't sold yet
you know I think if you're like that
cash might be the last cash I ever get
so I proved something out you would you
know think very differently about where
you put money yeah point you know for us
you were just in time inventory so look
if you bought it you're dieldrin on
Thursday we would actually make probably
the next again on Friday and ship it to
you Monday or Tuesday so we're like the
number one need we had for a really long
time as customer service cuz people be
like I ordered with you which is
completely fair for us we were just like
this is the only way we can afford to
grow the business because if we start
like putting 40k of that 50k into
inventory you know about 10k is barely
gonna last like three days but like you
know we're running ads some random
expense comes up there's this other
thing that we didn't realize that we had
to pay for and now we're broke no I
think no yeah as a DC company not having
inventory become something that you're
that kind of controls your uses you're
making lets you be a better you know D
to C business where you can really be
customer centric work on the product do
all this if you have you know three
times the amount you sell at a month
sitting and what you start having to
discount it ship it out sell it we don't
want any so I think really tight
inventory management
lets you stay customer centric in a
really healthy way
that boy and like to be honest as soon
as we expanded into brick-and-mortar
stores it was a revolutionary change in
the amount of inventory we had to hold
we went from holding like you know small
like you learn from holding six to seven
figures all of us have eight figures of
inventory and like you know the first
Pio from a company might be three
million dollars so you better have three
million dollars of inventory sitting in
your warehouse or anything ship to them
and that was like I mean that's a great
problem to have don't get me wrong and
given a much smaller scale you're just
like how am I supposed to have this much
inventory that just sounds impossible
and I think right now for walnut we did
a big retail rollout all the forecasting
and demand and planning is even you know
shot it's just so different and so far
behind well you know we can do in the DC
side that it surprised me at first but
ya caught with your pants down it's
complete garbage hundred-percent
retailers to give us forecast like how
much that he did or they're building
their own forecast like you know
retailing would be like you think you're
gonna go we're gonna need this and we
don't believe we don't know we don't
believe that you know what is going on
in your own store we've got this don't
worry about yeah so what did you do with
extra inventory it sounds like you know
creating these boxes back in 2000
2016-2017
I'm sure you had overly optimistic you
know at least once you were overly
optimistic when you're DT only how do
you discount it so that product into
every product and every month every box
was essentially exclusive right so we
weren't able to resell them so we spun
up a much bigger econ business for
customers so we you know wait 90 hundred
twenty days and give customers access to
products things like that but in general
like you know the better experience is
just for the product to be gone when
it's gone and to be executed so you know
we found ways to work through it but
yeah you got to be creative you know
yeah
and so then like in 27 2016 2017 when
you're burning need what is like the
peak burn and then what happens at the
end it's like it sounds like the
creditors at some point are like look we
need to be really like recaps
ya know I think we everybody kind of
realized we needed to get the business
record needed to get and then it was
going to be a more challenging raising
like
series B think that that would be
challenging given you know the changes
we had to make the business to get to
profitability and so you know we cut you
know if you think that from Pete we're
kind of a you know six million a month
of monthly op ex by the time we ended up
having to file and 2019 we'd cut down to
a million five
so we did massive structuring and
brought in some really great
restructuring advisors and stuff like
that to help really think about you know
hard decisions but I think it's gonna be
really relevant for folks now and
something I learned through this was
like you can do a lot more than you
think you can and giving yourself that
flexible if we had done that earlier
again we would have had a lot more
flexibility so went through a very long
process of just kind of rationalizing
the cost structure gotcha okay so if you
would if you thought if you would like
cut you should cut out the ex earlier
it's basically like if you have to redo
it you'd be like in 2016
let me start cutting up X significantly
right away well I think yeah it's you
know I think it's very you know when
you're in a growth mindset it's a
company that's important but when you're
it's hard to be in a growth mindset and
in a cost rationalization mindset at the
same time yeah and so we were trying to
do that dance for a long time where we
were where I think you know a healthy
dose of pain upfront get you back so you
can get back to that growth mindset and
keep everybody lined yes I think it's
difficult to be into two differences as
an organization at once and you know you
kind of you always want to be a
growth-oriented
I think it's a company but sometimes you
know it's you just got to make bigger
harder choices faster sure
and so tell me you like I like tell some
of the like effects things that you were
able to cut to go from six million in op
ex 21.5 I mean four and a half million
dollars in our backs a lot I'm sure
there's like you is it I'm sure there's
a lot of things right I'm sure some is
personnel I'm sure it's like you know I
don't look you know like your office
space or you need a thousand square-foot
shipping facility some is maybe reducing
the number of boxes you have what are
some of the things that you focus on
backs
yeah so you know we looked it areas
where we could you know
cut where Aries Marcia so we moved to a
3 PL in 2019 we built out a much bigger
team in the Philippines on the customer
support side because we were getting 350
thousand tickets it's a month and so we
kept our core team here in the US and
then had a team there just talked meant
going back and just you know talking to
Oliver enterprise software vendors and
really squeezing those prices down
because those can inflate quickly
you realize you have you know a hundred
and fifty users of something that
actually only 20 people are using so I
think we kind of across the board we had
great a head of Finance who helped lead
all that just like you know down to the
line-item everything was you know
everything was an option and we pushed
and cut and and you kind of go through
the whole business and you look for
opportunity and how long does it take to
go from six to 1.5 is that like a like
two two and half years two years yeah
okay gotcha
yeah and then ultimately you file for
bank robbery organization is that
correct yes
yeah and that happens in 2019 so that
happened last year exactly yep in August
of not sure look I honestly I think
there's gonna be a lot of companies that
are facing that this year as a result of
kovat as a result of dtc financing
drying up as a result of poor people
focusing on profitability tell me what
that process one in part entailed well
like how hard is it to go through that
and what happens at the other side but
from my perspective at what I would
imagine is the equity shareholders are
wiped out the dead holders now become
the equity holders they've got to put in
more attached to recapitalize the
business well I think that's what
happens but tell me what happened with
you guys and sort of how you went
through that process totally so I mean
you think your high-level overview is
pretty accurate there's chapter 11
chapter 7 we went through a chapter 11
process which is where your
restructuring and really trying to
figure out the best way to you know you
have creditors like trade creditors you
have your actual senior lenders and
subordinate lenders all that stuff so
you're you're really trying to go
through a process that maximizes the
value to creditors when you're going
through that and so for us we're just
the point where we had you know in 2018
spent more money on kind of legal and
professional fees that we had on sales
and marketing and you just get to a
point where you can
you can't grow and muscle your way
through it and so you know at chapter 11
restructuring is the yes approach there
and so with that went through that in
August and you know as part of that went
through essentially an auction for the
business at that point where the largest
creditor you know bid and acquired you
know acquired the business through that
process it was fairly quick in October
is when they the acquisition happened
fitters at the table a lot of other
folks looked at it but yeah the way the
the credit bidding and all the stuff
works
you know it's primarily the large
creditors that have the best shot of the
deals yeah and and then but the actual
process itself like you know the
Delaware Court is actually you know
they're they're supportive of employees
and of keeping the business up and
running their goal is really to like you
try to facilitate a fair process and
keep the business operating so it was
yeah I think from my kind of my my my
expectations of the process to kind of
how it's all played out it's been really
smooth and the business is growing again
and it wasn't it's obviously disruptive
but it definitely is set up in a way
that you know keeps keeps things from
falling apart while you're going through
the restructuring itself okay I won't
ask more questions about the
restructuring but before I get there do
you still spend 75 percent of your time
focusing on like your cap table and your
lenders or is it now like you're
spending more of your time in the
business no I mean I think now you know
it no we're that's all done yeah that
was done when essentially is the
business is coming out of the out of
that acquisition process in October so a
lot of it's just been getting rebuilding
customer trust getting products out you
know the last year is we were really
getting constrained financially started
to have some delays we the whole time
through the whole process we made sure
that there wasn't a big impact on the
customer experience but that last like
six months were straining to get a
product out there were delays things
like that that we have been focused
really on since then turning the
customer experience piece which for
which gets lost in all the short company
building running pieces has always been
the you know the goal so
it seems live in focus there gotcha like
during bankruptcy basically was just
hard to meet not only the financial
obligations of their debt holders but
also just like customer expectations as
you're running the business of getting a
product out on time and so you're trying
to sort of turn that ship around and say
hey consumers we're on in this now we're
gonna ship our stuff on time we're back
yeah that's really the even more so the
pre-bankruptcy piece once you're in
bankruptcy and you have the definite
ancing then you can operate much more
normal course your vendors have
protection and everything else so that
was really when we filed it in August is
when we turned kind of all the operating
teams to focus on let's get all these
products that are late in and out and
try to get back to some kind of normal
operating case and just so people
understand dip financing it's like
debtor-in-possession finance thing which
means that like a lender is gonna fund
you to continue running the business
through bankruptcy and as that happens
they get like a day of the first mean
position because they're basically like
this is post bankruptcy and we're giving
you money in order to continue your
business yep uh-huh so how much is ever
in possession financing do you get to
continue around business so we had it
was I think publicly ten million dollar
facility that came in when we were doing
that and so that came in and allowed us
to do handle a ton of this the stuff
that I kind of backlog of things we
needed to handle and so what is the
tablet and what is a cap table I won't
talk about the business as well sort of
post bankruptcy you're seeing 20/20 but
what is it a cap table look like post
bankruptcy so you had up front and
Robert Downey jr. and 15 million dollars
in debt imagine a fraud and blabber down
here now sort of wiped off the cap table
and the guy who is her largest lender
and sort of put in more money in the
debtor-in-possession financing is now
your largest taps like the largest
equity holder on the cap table yeah the
group the group that did the acquisition
it's basically a reset of the entity and
all that right so that that group the
there's essentially there's the old an
old company in the new company and then
that whole new company everything
transitions there and then how do you
remain incentivized because like you
know there's that old company and you
were like this you know you're the CEO
of that old company that's here with a
new company and like do they negotiate
with you to give you an equity stake and
incentives as well
it happened I mean to in a lot of these
cases that you know they want some
continuity and in leadership and yeah so
you know most of the folks at the
company today or folks that were the
company prior to the bankruptcy yeah I
and we're you know I early team back now
my goal has really been to make the
transition as effective as possible
yeah and work with the team on that I
care a lot about the brand and want to
to survive and be strong and so I think
you know I think that's really been the
focus is can we get get like let
everybody get back to like a normal
operating environment which is all I
think the team is really you know we
have big chunk of the company is in
design and product development and you
know people want to see sound like a
positive story tied to the the products
we put out in the world yeah well one I
certainly think looking you know you've
been working on the business for eight
years
I can imagine there's an incredible
amount of like your own personal sweat
blood and tears built into it and I
think a lot of times people get lost on
that like I don't even work at native
today and I still think about it on a
daily basis I'm like this is what I beat
this is Howard you know look whatever it
like tweet about it and tweeted me and
they're like I'm trying it like okay if
you don't have a good experience let me
know I'm like actually I have no
financial interest in this and if you
tell me you hate it there's not anything
I can do about it either yeah but there
is a certain there's a lot of like
personal like loyalty to the brand and
especially if you've been doing it for
eight years totally and I think the
customers that are still with us from
there I mean there's just a lot of you
want to see it do well and you want to
see it
you know be something that the people
love yeah and so what is working for the
brand today like we're like what you
know you must have cut down on our backs
significantly and you know you've
probably retooled marketing where you're
like hey Ivan some of the influencers
that years ago you're still using but at
that Facebook that's when is it a
million dollars a month any longer what
is working today in order to grow the
brand again so I mean a lot of the same
traditional DC channels are still
working well I think you know the
dynamics
shift you know depending on what's going
on you know I think we've seen like on
Facebook for example the last 60 days
costs come down
but in general it's manageable right I
think all the same best practice for us
it's kind of like if you're if for our
product it's not something that is a
consumable that you need it's something
that you want and so
having trusted brands and partners tell
you that this is something that you
should have yes your influence or things
like that is still a great channel that
works and I think a lot of its just
figuring out the unit economics but
we're seeing you know all the same
channels that work before work well
we're not really and some of our like
higher cost channels like remnant
television things like that we're not
we're not doing anything there but we're
looking our most efficient channels and
our best channels Facebook included and
leaning into those and being disciplined
and you know I think again the the
actual underlying market dynamics that
made this work well which is you know
there's a million different Marvel T's
on amazon.com and our core demo is not
going in to target to buy a Marvel
t-shirt that at like curated collectible
consumer products perience had it really
shifted throughout the eight years we've
been running the business and so you
know once it was kind of liberated from
a lot of the you know the the corporate
issues you know yeah it's there and I
think we're looking at you know new
experiments we have a thing called loot
launcher we're doing which is like a
crowdfunding approach so we can take
more you know do a larger number of
partnerships try more things out be more
experimental and so we're using that
crowdfunding model so I think we're just
talking about that is that like is that
like sort of almost not Groupon because
it's not disconnected but it's that like
if we sell 7,000 of these will go make
all this stuff exactly captain
exactly Labs yep so we're doing we're
doing more of those and I think the
pre-order model works really well and so
we're I think there's there's still a
ton of demand in the category and I
think direct-to-consumer is such a great
way it's where we're all consuming the
content building out kind of new new
economic models around those
opportunities there's a ton of time we
can do there's so if you really shift it
sounds like a month that has shifted
from like doing a better job
understanding demand over the last like
two years or maybe three years where
you're like you know we're really
optimistic about this new box of
conscious new box didn't go as
well as we wanted to be up all this
excess inventory to let's pre sell this
box let's make sure at least 7,000
people want it before we make it let's
not make a max of 10,000 so we don't
have a ton of excess inventory is that
is that something that's is that
accurate or is that not accurate percent
right I think yeah
turn curves are all fairly predictable
but they're all different by product
lines also when you're getting it in
2530 different subscription lines like
even with models that work well like the
bike demand planning and things moving
it's just a lot you know asking yourself
to xq on that dance perfectly every
month is challenging so building in some
some flexibility and some predictability
has been super helpful that is you know
that's so mind-blowing because it's
almost the exact opposite of what you'd
expect you went from being having no
discipline basically early on or not no
discipline of course but basically
saying look we're we're operating on a
gut perspective and we think that'll
work
and there's money here so you scale the
business and you think okay now I
actually trust my gut more I've been in
this for four or five years I'm like you
know we're not 100 million dollar run
rate we have hundreds of thousands of
subscribers we've gonna run we've only
raised $25,000 to actually you have to
trust your gut even less when you get
that big because the decisions you make
are so monumental the ship is so large
that when you're making those decisions
they they can be not mortal blows but
significant blows yeah I think we have a
lot more data today than we did as we
were sailing so to not use that data
would be foolish right and you know I
think we are in our growth model was you
know Paul Graham and put out that essay
on growth and a good friend of Y
Combinator at the time and so our you
know our whole growth model was let's
you know we started at 20% of months and
that really essentially worked for three
and a half years and so we had some kind
of North Star growth metrics and then we
all could focus your honor around a
single product it's a different dip when
you have products in different stages
their life cycle totally different
offerings price points we saw you know
just a very different approach to
managing those different stages of the
product life cycle is neat yeah that
makes a ton of sense I guess like I'm
like it blows my mind that you trust
your gut less or look I think it's
accurate because I think look at media I
should have done more of that like I
should have trusted my gut less when we
reach scale instead I was just like I
can make no mistake I'm obviously in
I know good I know how to do everything
of course I do
I've generated all of its revenue Nevada
and in reality I should've been like
well if I make a decision and it goes
wrong now we've ordered an extra 250
thousand products it cost us $500,000
and think it's a much larger mistake
today than it was you know three years
ago and what did you guys that's how was
your gut yeah just ask question how's it
like when you guys expand it outside of
Yoda right like weirder areas where your
gut was just totally wrong I don't trust
my gut any longer actually I mean the
reality is that like once we expended
outside of tiara we were a part of PMG
and so there are a lot of like different
interests playing alongside of where we
could expand whether we would expand
like you know we have to sit within a
PNG division and that PNG division
really owns the PL and so as a result
there's more limitations look you know I
would I was like okay great we're now
part of PNG we can make whatever we want
PNG make some paper towels we could make
native paper towels of that you know
very much was not the case we had more
independence in terms of making those
decisions pre PNG and we did post p.m.
so your guns man egde 12 by the you know
we're even inventory on seasonal sense
things to that effect and when I made
wrong decisions there were a lot more
consequential and I think overall I
liked I was trying to you know you try
to maximize revenues here almost like I
want to I'd rather have too much of this
product instead of too little until your
business is large enough where you're
like I see how many things are on my
belt like all this excess inventory that
I ordered too much of is getting to be a
huge you know huge asset on my balance
sheet and it's not a good asset it's not
going anywhere and moving forward like I
shifted my mindset to be like I'd rather
sell out of this sense rather than have
too much of the Sun and now I think that
wasn't as we brought in a bunch of CPG
finance execs that was I think the
number one thing like scaling up DBC
brands can do is expense your excess
inventory is cost of goods in month
because I think I've seen a lot of folks
that you know if the image were just
hearing your balance sheet your P&L
looks great but the reality is that's
excess inventory and you start to
realize maybe 10% of gross margin should
just be rich
down inventory costs yeah so there's a
bunch of things you can do to like not
convince yourself that the models
working as well as is that I think can
help companies duel to just a better
more discipline around forecasting
demand planning an inventory yeah
great advance I I guess I have two more
questions one is what you wish you had
done differently do you wish you had
never taken a debt do you wish you were
more focused on topics early on
do you wish you hadn't expanded into as
many boxes or do you say hey you know
what like learned a ton and this we did
what was right I think you have you
learn a lot right and so I think during
the learnings you have to make sure
that's a positive piece of it because
yeah the pain and agony is is gonna come
in those moments and you gotta find some
healthy way to reframe it I think
there's a ton of things I would have
done differently there was you know
we've gotten so used to hyper growth
that the route was taking and the kind
of confidence to solve hard problems on
the fly we just didn't need to think
that way and I think I become a much
better communicator with boards lenders
equity you know that that like really
important structure that sits on top of
the business then really if you're gonna
it really needs to be managed the right
way you have a lot of great mentors and
through a lot of experiences I think
could have done better there and I think
like I said it just goes back to I think
risk management and you know making hard
decisions earlier faster and bigger then
then you'd like to yeah and we had a you
know this CEOs done like twenty
turnarounds come into the company it
advised and we're talk about cuts it's
like have you ever cut too deep when
you're doing a cut and he's like I
always cut too deep and I never regret
it and I think like wow I didn't
internalize at the time I I think part
of the point is because you can always
build back up and then you eliminate
existential risk and so I think I think
there's a lot of lessons there that a
lot of companies are going to go through
during this period of time which is yeah
the world has changed know that and make
big decisive action more so than you
think you need to right now because it
gives you the flexibility when you know
which there's gonna be a lot of
incumbents that are too
/ distracted and debt-laden right now
they do a lot of these b2c brands
capitalise on but you need to be in a
position to capitalize so you know make
hard big decisions fast and so do you
think he's right you can like you should
cut deep like you should cut too deep
and you don't regret it or did you cut
too deep and you don't regret it was he
right I think in the face which was much
earlier in our lifecycle it was the
right advice I think there's obviously a
point you need to like customer
experience in all these companies is
number one so this just has to be in a
way that is maximized as customer
experience so you can't like if you have
20 thousands and customer support
tickets you need enough folks to respond
to those tickets if you're delivering a
product you're competing with everybody
else it's got to be the best product
like if you had to start making trade
off and your product quality decision
that's not really a business anymore so
I think outside of that like but really
know what those core areas are and then
everything else has to be fit that is
fantastic advice and like I feel first
your this is my favorite interview that
I've done ever in my entire life because
not only did you you can read the screen
like - a hundred on $25,000 in like
money $25,000 capital invested which is
literally nothing compared to the you
know Dollar Shave club's of the world
and Harry's of the world voices - you
went through like Jake look I feel like
a lot of people and myself included
never had you know I had a hard day at
work but I never like my hard day work
was a good day for you I never went
through a recession and like in many
ways I was a real coward about the
business you said I'm gonna raise money
I'm gonna go to the mattresses this is
260 billion dollar business and I'm the
take advantage of it me I was a
real and I was just like we're
gonna hire very slowly because I think
I'm gonna run out of money every day I
don't know what the I'm doing over
here there's like you know everything is
going wrong and there's gonna be a
torpedo hits the side of this boat at
any given time and so for us we didn't
face those problems but it was intense
but but I knew what I knew that we
wouldn't face those problems because
there's no there's there's nothing wrong
with that I think it was gonna
you got through that like very few
people like you know very few people go
through those hard days come out the
other end and they're like we're gonna
build another sustainable business that
requires an incredible amount of
tenacity and courage and B but you know
it's not easy to go to a bunch of
employees or look we're not gonna keep
this fulfillment center anymore
outsource this we're gonna outsource
some of our customer service we have a
core team here but when outsource them
but like it's not easy to get up day
after day and sort of make those
decisions rationalized Rob that's for
two years come through they'd be like
now we're gonna start building again but
that requires more tenacity than I've
ever seen that's like a G like
you know General Electric type of
restructuring it's really spectacular
and like I'm in all the results of that
today that I would have been in 2017 or
2016 and we've been no I really
appreciate that I think the you know the
one the the thing for me has been the
benefit to of scaling once we got to
bring in a lot of seasoned folks so when
I was having a hard time making hard
decisions folks hasn't seen this a few
times yeah like these decisions aren't
don't you're overthinking these things
like these we have to do we have to do
and so I think great leadership teams
especially these companies get to scale
folks need to start removing themselves
from decision making because yeah we're
so emotionally tied to the brands to the
products it's hard to make hard
trade-offs when it's your baby
and yeah yeah so you know I think you
know getting better and finding great
advisors making yourself lessee ultimate
decision maker and helping having people
that know certain parts of the business
better than you help you make the really
hard choices is is been you know huge
for me and those advisors you know
asking people I trust
yeah I think in any of these areas you
know there's a hole on the restructuring
a debt side there's a whole separate
universe that most of us never interact
with that does this and you know it's
the same way we you know I'm the growth
and marketing side we were scaling up
and I was trying to figure out who the
best DC marketers who just hitting
everybody up and learning as much as you
can so I think it's the same kind of
general principles they're out there
they're ready to help okay two final
questions one what is your favorite
video game assuming you play video games
and - what is your favorite box being in
the last okay so I think
everybody I think this is the moment for
VR to really take off so there's a game
called pistol whip an oculus that's
amazing that's so fun do you like
literally or your arms are dead within
10 minutes because you're just a little
running around like in this it's amazing
or you like working people you're a
pistol whipping shooting first-person
shooter or like if you don't have a VR
this is the time and VR head says yeah
oculus is the one how long have you had
not to us a year okay yeah we had one D
we haven't the office we like we've had
him for a long time we had an
interaction but yet we've had it for a
while but ya know like it will change
it's a there's beat Sabre there's some
amazing games that like more casual
gamers can get really into so but yeah
pistol-whip is amazing and I'm gonna go
to oculus and pistol it up today yep it
sold out obviously because everybody had
the same but yeah waiting list yeah no
it's it's but he'll be back soon and
then what was your second question what
what has been your favorite box that
loot crate has ever sent out over the
last eight years we you know one of my
favorites is we had I'm trying to
actually member the we have themed names
for everyone so they like curated but it
had a replica hub like a one-fifth scale
replica lover board like a Doc Brown
when he's pulling the to jump starts
yeah there is like a collectible figure
we had an it had a back to the future be
excellent to each other sure which is
like the best message of all time and
it's just like yeah held my favorite
favorite gear there's where did that box
come at that was in the 20 and of 2015
okay always fascinating yeah yeah Chris
this is amazing thanks so much for
sharing your journey I feel like you've
got a lot more experience than those
people in direct-to-consumer you've seen
a lot more things when it comes to
direct to consumer and like very few
people would be as honest and upfront
and as open as you've been so I really
appreciate that as a founder and I
really like realized you know the amount
of tenacity and courage you've had to go
through this and build a successful
business on the other end all this you
is is superhuman and like heroic and so
I'm like I hope I hope people in your
company if I were to your company I
would think of you as the superhero that
would go box you're one of those people
in the direct consumer industry and
thanks so much for being here and yeah I
think this is so far and this is really
great
I can't believe that yeah no this is
awesome thanks so much we gotta talk to
[Music]